it's now at a point where
sure we're still like you have more and
more and more and more people
piling up at the bottom um and
i'm at the point now and i think many
are it needs to be fundamentally
shifted and so you can't you can't tweak
on the margins you can't change the
inside
has to be fundamental and that's what
always drew me to universal basic income
it drove me to cash
payments that sort of cash relief those
of us who really
really believe in in cash see it for all
of those reasons see it for people's
ability
to really be who they're meant to be i
mean it's not going to solve
every issue but certainly it can solve
for
you know being able to say i don't have
to worry whether i'm going to eat next
week
you know i don't have to worry if i have
to juggle between trying to keep the
lights on
and figuring out how to take care of the
needs of my child so
yeah i think that it's it's it's
providing us
with an opportunity to reimagine um a
broken
really you know broken systems that have
been in play for for decades
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks special
thursday episode as usual on the future
of
i'm zach grauman your co-host today
and today we're talking about the future
of poverty a bit and we've got
a incredible woman named ann price
joining
she's the president of the insight
center for community economic
development she's based in oakland
and what i wanted to talk to her about
and learn from her
is what's happening on the ground when
you're talking about poverty and where
this is going so we started this
movement
around universal basic income and cash
relief and it is
taken off objectively speaking you've
got cities all over
the country piloting you cash relief you
got
chicago boston la um hopefully where i
live
new york city eventually but what does
that mean mechanically and what are the
other problems that
this may not solve and one of the things
we talk about ann and i talk about is
narratives and how
mainstream movements and mainstream
press narratives mainstream stories that
we've heard
um like pick yourself up by the
bootstraps or things like that
how they shape policy and how they shape
what we're trying to
affect when it comes to change
particularly around poverty and both
good and bad
so it's a fascinating conversation i
learned a lot i'm confident you will
learn a lot so tune in right now the
future of poverty with ann
price right here on yang speaks
[Music]
all right it is my pleasure i'm so
excited
i had to um i told her before we started
recording that
professionally stalk her as i was i
found her on an article talking about
economic inclusion
and i think on affordable housing but
i'm
honored to welcome the wonderful anne
price
to yang speaks in our episodes on the
future of she's the president of the
insight center
for community economic development and
i would say from the outside looking in
an expert on
what many the many ways our economy is
broken and actually doing work to fix
that which is something i always respect
so and
welcome to the show thank you for
joining thanks for having me on zach i'm
excited about this conversation
me too um so let's um so i've got
it's been fun for me to kind of learn
about you but why don't we start with
with you
share a little bit about um about your
about your background how you ended up
um as president of someone of an org
doing great work i know it's not
necessarily a traditional or easy path
so tell us about you
i really grew up watching my parents who
really
you know fought for the most
marginalized
folks my mom was a schoolteacher in
milwaukee
and had you know her kids were really
living in
abject poverty and and my dad did some
work on
um housing and working with tenants to
ensure they had quality housing so
i really have had all my life this sense
of
of social and racial justice so i you
know i
i consider myself like an uber
generalist i've worked on so many issues
medicaid hunger i was a child advocate i
worked on community college issues
and i was really drawn to insight
because they were tackling
this big issue called the racial wealth
gap and i just really wanted to be part
of that so that's how i landed at
insight
we have that in common my mom was a
teacher as well she taught special ed
um in jacksonville florida
and not the the nicest part of town she
used to tell me it was like a you know
i mean she's the the kids were were in a
tough area and
what what did your mom teach and okay i
i love so you see as a young age you it
instilled in you you know
oh yeah my mom taught um kindergarten in
first grade and she was one of the
one of the early teachers that taught
really young children how to read
you know she'd get her kids up to first
to third grade reading level so
i was like pretty in awe of her because
she was
uh she was awesome teacher um i was a
little scared of her in the classroom to
be honest
but she uh did you you took her mom your
mom was your teacher
no no no she would have to come in she'd
have me like you know
like great papers sit with her while she
was teaching on my
you know when you have one of those
teacher conference days and
and you know the reality is is i grew up
in the suburbs and she she wanted to
really show me
you know really how different my
my education was my school which was
pristine and beautiful
um and the school that she taught in
which really you know had gates at the
windows
and um you know where people where kids
didn't have the resources that i had so
i knew that
you know she was quietly teaching me
about inequality
how did you end up deciding the career
path well you know i
honestly didn't know what i wanted to do
i changed my major in college maybe
three or four times um
landed on economics and i really liked
it
um but then realized that to go to
graduate school like this would just be
like a ton of math
and so i was like economics is just like
math
and um econometrics if anyone's done
this you're like
this isn't as funny as it sounds this is
not as fun as it actually sounds
so um i chose policy school instead i
really wanted to solve like a real
real world problems and you know i
i wanted to go to new york here was this
kid from wisconsin and i went to school
in virginia and
i wanted to be in a place where i knew
these world
were significant issues these were
world-class issues
and i wanted to be able to be in the
midst of that like
solving problems and so you know i i had
a very securities route to kind of get
to where i was i
um you know just decided to say i'm
going to try policy and it ended up
being
the greatest choice i could make so i i
majored in public policy and one of the
reasons for me was uh
i love the concept of the decisions of
very few
impacting the lives of many there was
something in me like who's making that
decision
and are they qualified um and the big
example of me was
nafta um so for those of you who are not
policy wonks or had to sit through
courses listening this so
north american free trade agreement um
basically
the long issue you probably know more
just much about more about design demand
but uh
basically us auto companies specifically
were getting crushed by honda and toyota
they're making better cars to be honest
um
and so we freaked out we're like okay
we're going to lower taxes between
mexico and canada
um which basically is like raising taxes
on japan where they're making these
great cars
but what the which in some ways great
for our u.s
car companies at that time was our bread
and butter when bill clinton was present
in 90s but
what did it do we subsidized there are
other externalities if you will and one
of the biggest ones is that we subsidize
our food in the united states
um so we're providing farmers massive
subsidies to make their corn cheaper
whatever they're making
and so because of that we had no taxes
in mexico there was no it was free trade
with mexico so we flooded their market
um and mexico was like 50 small farmer
economy so their
farms get wiped out and then we have an
immigration challenge in the united
states
um where they start fleeing the united
states and so it was like this
mind-blowing
who made that decision why didn't they
think about it who's at the table
were there things when you were studying
that was like the
oh yeah i need to be i need to be there
making the decision because these idiots
whoever it was
um like aren't gonna aren't gonna know
what i see like what
do you have that kind of thing well you
know there's there's so many issues
when i um went to new york i thought i
wanted to study housing
and um i knew that's where i wanted to
go and then
i i realized i didn't want to do that
you know it's
i mean housing is really complex it's
important issue of course
but you know i really wanted to dig in
more on the social safety net
and um you know saw a range of different
different issues problems at that time i
mean i was in new york in the midst of
um you know the crack epidemic in the
midst
of the aids crisis right and there were
um you know a number of of issues that
touched families so
yeah i mean i i really thought wow let
me dig in on the social safety net
because i thought it would be
it's such a big challenge so i love big
challenges i think that's what
um you and i and andrew definitely have
an in common in that
um and the social safety net was one of
the reasons andrew wrote his book and
eventually ran for president
we are we're just behind let's dive into
the insight center
what drew you there and what what type
of work are you guys doing now and then
i'd love to unpack um
kind of your ideas there too but let's
start with insight center
yeah you know we are a women of
color-led nonprofit
and we drive structural and
transformative change
to build economic inclusion and racial
equity right for the most marginalized
and so we use a a unique theory of
change and we
really strive to shift power and agency
and economic policy by unapologetically
centering those closest to the problems
um
and and and driving that from the
from the center of those who are most
marginalized and so we do
three things really we we do research
and advocacy
um our research really is in service of
campaigns and service of
advocacy efforts we want to do
groundbreaking research that really
unearths
the root causes of problems we focus on
narrative change and i know that this is
big
and the work that we've done around
guaranteed income
um that we really that that really
narratives are dr
that drive policy right we always say
that narratives
eat policy for lunch right so they
really shape how we think about problems
so we do a lot of work around narrative
change and just thought leadership we
joke that look policy is not going to
win the elections
um when we're running for president
although he's like but one or two big
policy ideas like a vision wills it's
not like
you know but if you're getting the weeds
on stuff most people are like hey what
do you stand for
um so i'm so curious about the narrative
piece of this because one of the things
that was frustrating for us was um and
i've said this on podcast four so when
we were
first running for office we thought we
were going to be the furthest left
candidate um because like i want to give
everybody money like that's the most
progressive idea
you know can you get more left than that
like if you're a republican against
handouts like that's due
to you know that's like the antithesis
um
and but andrew um
while being as a democrat his whole life
was not speaking
in maybe the narrative language or um of
some of the people doing
let's call it let's i think there wasn't
a lot of work on guaranteeing income but
people doing work on the social safety
net there was a disconnect
and so he was pinged i mean we've been
called a white nationalist we've been
called
uh like things that are just even called
republican which
he's like hey this was dr king's vision
for
you know in his book chaos or community
so
like what what are your thoughts on how
the narrative kind of shapes policy and
in some of the stuff you guys do to
counteract that
you know there's a number of dominant
narratives but
you know the major the major narrative
that
we deal with in this country is a
personal responsibility narrative and it
really says that in bootstraps which is
yeah that
i call them two sides of the same coin
right they're all rooted
in the notion that basically the
mechanism to success
is through your own hard work and grit
and self-determination
and you know if you're not successful if
you're poor it's because of your own
personal failings it's something
that you've done wrong you make bad
choices and
you know what it really really calls for
is not investing
in people right because why should the
government
intervene when it's really everyone's
responsibility to
make sure that they can find their own
path to economic uh
you know mobility and prosperity and
it's been
a really harmful narrative and it's it's
not innocent at all right there's been
you know millions hundreds of millions
of dollars
invested in this narrative because what
it means is that we can
you know really be you know it means
that we can be dominated by like
corporate culture right corporate
concentration
we can dismiss we can say we need
smaller government we need
um we you know some of our our
government entities should be replaced
with private entities like libraries for
example right should be run by private
companies
and so it's very damaging um it also
impedes our ability
to pass good policy right if people
believe
look there's nothing that you can do
because basically
it's everyone's responsibility to make
their own way then why do we need
government intervention why do we need
government investment
right and so you know when we think
about our social safety net
that has been a predominant narrative
driving policy and it's so
easy to weaponize that narrative
and you can just racialize it you know
when you start using words like
when you start using words like cheats
when you use words like these
people are lazy they don't want to work
and we see that narrative now
with unemployment insurance right what's
being said you know what people are
going back to
they you know this is a disincentive for
people to go back to work
because inherently we believe that you
know there are
groups of folks that don't want to work
and it's all around deservedness this is
all about who's deserving
and so it's a it's a major reason why we
have such a weak social safety net
the reason we saw that even when um cash
rolled out
you know and people needed unemployment
benefits the systems couldn't handle the
numbers because they were designed not
to really allow people to get
unemployment insurance right
um our welfare system is really meant
for people not to get access to it i
mean it sounds really counterintuitive
but it's a cycle it's a cycle and mainly
the cycle is it's not that people want
to stay on it and not that we don't have
rules to get people off of it
but you know when you go out and you get
a job
and you just make a little bit more that
makes you lose your housing
that makes you lose a child care subsidy
you're actually in worse
shape so why do we have a system that
makes you worse off
right so that's what we have in play and
that's why i think
even with cash the idea that it really
is addressing a shortcoming in our
social safety net
we see that it's just like when people
can make their own decisions
they will buy food they will pay off
debt
they will um you know stash a little bit
of money away
we've seen the results from what can
happen when we can allow people to make
their own choices
and the social safety net is all about
controlling
people's decisions constraining them um
telling them what they can buy and what
they can't buy um
and it keeps people in a box it keeps
them cemented in place
so yeah it's one of those it's a system
that remains
somewhat hidden um there's been little
political will on both
in both parties to actually
radically reimagine this system i just
loved everything you just said and i'm
learning too which is um in terms of
specific ways you're talking about it i
so
aoc said something funny um
funny and painfully true that you know
pulling yourself by the bootstraps
doesn't work if you don't have
bootstraps
at all right um and there's a story i
remember from
high school and i went to um a public
school
in elmwood right outside of hartford and
um
so we were really diverse pretty big
school
and one of my buddy's name was alex
gonzalez i'll come gonzo
um smart kid and he was this huge
linebacker but like a teddy bear i'll
never forget one day come after practice
i always thought i was i was pretty like
i was a hard worker like most people are
and i um it was like seven o'clock we
just finished football practice
and i was like we were leaving it was
like um going home to
start homework right here two three
hours of homework you have every night
and i was like do you need a ride he's
like no i'm good i gotta go to work i'm
like what do you mean you gotta go to
work he's like yeah
i gotta go start my shift at
baskin-robbins um
i'm like well he's like yeah you know if
i want to pay for my cell phone
um i gotta i gotta work and
it was this now i was i was a paperboy i
worked a little and i paid for you know
certain things like that but
the it was the the jarring moment like
all right that stuff if you have less
time to your homework it's going to hit
your gpa
it's going to hurt your extracurriculars
these sort of things it's just being a
slow
small slip and it has nothing to do with
hard work because he was working his
tail off
um and it was like one minor example
that i'm sure of a billion that you
could think of and know off top of your
head
um why do you think you said this
there's been little political will
on both sides of the aisle um
and that's going to include leaders from
every demographic right
um why
i really think it comes back to
deservedness and who we think is
deserving
and we still see poverty as
a as a moral feeling you know
we don't see it as a structural issue
and
you know it's it's really hard to move
the needle
when you've been you've been hearing
this narrative
you know i mean we don't even probably
recognize how much we hear that
narrative
about um who's deserving about people
who don't
want to work hard um and
it's it's just it's something that we
quietly hear
like our whole lives and so you know to
break through
it takes it takes intentionality right
this isn't gonna just happen on its own
right
and people didn't just invest in this
narrative
for no reason it has tremendous
political gain
right it means you can deregulate it
means that you
can um lower tax corporate taxes it
means all of these things that actually
benefit
um a few and so it's like i said it's
it's
in no way innocent so i think that is
why i've seen that in my work
uh you know both at a city level and at
a national level where you have
legislators or like well what if it
means that people aren't going to work
or
you know what if they're trying to
really scam the system because we always
think that people are trying to scam the
system i
i remember in new york i was working on
um you know
food stamp at the time called food stamp
now it's called snap
over payments and these were like like
really like glitches system glitches
where people might get
literally five to ten dollars more in
their in their
um in their food stamps and there was a
whole
unit just you know dedicated to fraud
and we found out it cost two hundred
fifty dollars for every dollar you
recover right cost 250 dollars
and what the major issue was like it was
just like
they were small amounts i'm telling you
five to ten dollars typically
um and when you know i went to a
a local council person i said we've got
to stop this
and he's like i just can't the narrative
behind it is just
you know what i'm stopping cheats and
i'm like these aren't cheats you know
like we need a better
maybe we need a better computer system i
don't know but it
is i think there's just a real pull
for us because people can really utilize
that
that narrative to talk about people's
morality
to talk about um you know we don't want
people cheating and scamming the system
we don't
we want to make sure people are
responsible um you know and and those
things that
are really deeply embedded in our
psyches like it's deeply embedded
it doesn't matter you're you're where
you live or your political affiliation
or
a race it's it's something that pretty
much americans believe
no politician wants to be the guy or gal
that's like oh
i'm gonna let i'm gonna we have this
fraud prevention department that
prevents people from stealing your tax
dollars i'm gonna be the person that
gets rid of that like no one wants to
publicly say that even though they know
what you know is like look it's super
expensive the roi is terrible
um and you know you're just making
frankly the people who are benefiting
from it generally their lives worse but
the big thing for me
and where andrew and i would talk about
a lot and andrew's big on this in the
trail if we ever got the chance to speak
was that
that should be the cost of doing
business
in this situation because the real
expense
is having people in poverty because what
happens is we nickel and we save the
nickel and dimes on the front end but we
pay for it 10x
on the back end whether that's our
housing shelters or healthcare
or you go like that's where the real
money where you have a very when you end
up with a poor
disadvantaged society you you end up
with
it it's more it seems more expensive you
want to make the like the argument that
this is a cost-saving initiative it's
ridiculous it's a fundamentally
ridiculous argument
um the economy will do better you'll
have more tax dollars to spend if
everybody's participating
fact um so that's
a narrative it's not there it needs to
be there so i'm feeling i know your
frustration i feel it too
okay i like you live a very busy as we
all do very busy stressful lives
and when you don't have a good mattress
to come home to and crash on it sucks
and i'm grateful that
uh we've partnered with helix sleep and
i've been using a helix mattress and
sleeping on it and it's amazing
helix sleep is awesome and here's how
they work they give you like this
two-minute sleep quiz
you fill it out based on your
preferences you like a softer firm
mattress you sleep on your side you turn
your neck do you sleep hot whatever it
is
and they match you with the perfect
mattress i get this king mattress get
the perfect balance for me it's the
helix lux
the california king it's freaking
massive and i love it to
death and it's not just me helix was
awarded number one best overall mattress
pick in 2020 by gq and wired magazine
literally the people that rate
mattresses for a living
picked this number one multiple times so
here's the deal go to helixsleep.com
yang take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will get you the best
sleep of your life
for real they got a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it
but you're going to when they ship it to
you in this beautiful box comes out
roll it out super easy super awesome so
right now they're offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
yang that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
for up to 200
off and two free pillows check it out
[Music]
what does success look like as you when
you guys work you know like how are you
like is there something you can measure
towards because it's such a big complex
problem what's your piece that you can
affect or what what is it what does it
look like when you guys get a win
yeah i mean certainly we there's certain
um legislation we've worked on where
we've seen that
be successful in past we've seen
how our research has contributed to
you know policy wins and a greater
understanding
of an issue so we can certainly see that
you know um i think that some of our
work
at insight we really are sometimes um
ahead of where other folks are and
they're thinking and i say head like
future
thinking i mean you know we'll put an
idea out there and initially people will
say wow that's kind of crazy
so i mean for example we
are very much our worker centered on
racial equity
and you know we've come to really think
that racial equity is also becoming kind
of muddied like what does it mean how do
you know you're successful how do you
measure it
and so we really you know start to think
about
a foundational architecture of our
economy
that's built on anti-blackness right um
and i'll explain that in just a second
but you know um
so we really we developed this this this
framework that says you know we can we
can center blackness and policy
right to address anti-blackness and
really address the most marginalized
um and so some people see that as
radical
but it's a logical framework to solve
for racism embedded in our economy in
our politics and so
that's what i mean by kind of pushing
the envelope on some of these issues
so when we think about anti-blackness
and i call it a foundational
architecture because our economy was
built on this very notion of anti-black
racism
and when we think about how our economy
was shaped
through slavery right that
this was not just you know the fact that
there were some plantations and some
you know slaves and staff worked on them
this was a global economy
right um and it
it it really allowed us as a nation to
develop
like business models from this
architecture right
um you know how we thought about
collateral how we thought about
depreciation
even how we thought about labor and
how you can actually yes and how you
could really
um you know extract from labor how you
could
force labor to be more productive right
and you know we can see it today in
surveillance and we think about how we
can push
workers to produce more um
so this isn't something that this is
very foundational to our nation's
economy
but also to the rules of our economic
policies
right i just talked about the social
safety net and our social safety net
is predicated on tropes like a welfare
queen uh narrative it is
it's it's even when people say when you
think about poverty who do you think
about
right and people often say black people
right um
and because of that you know we have
very punitive systems
and so what if we really just thought
about
um considering the most marginalized and
and thought about
what would what would it look like in
our policy if we can
actually solve for anti-blackness that's
a new way of thinking about racial
equity
um and i think it's a very unifying
actually it's a very it's a way to build
solidarity because we're all
impacted by it think about this right so
when you think about medicaid expansion
and the fact that a lot of states chose
have chosen not to expand medicaid
and you listen to the narratives behind
that it's these same kinds of things
about
deservedness who is it hurting yes
it can be it's hurting black people but
it's also hurting white people and maybe
even
to a greater degree right so these you
know
anything that's really predicated on
this notion ensnares everyone that's in
it ensnares everyone that has to
that needs that policy that needs that
program
um you know to survive uh to be able to
be you know uh moved up economically
uh it's it's it's really fun it's
something that we don't talk about
because it's just
so it's so difficult for us to think
about
our economy in that way but when we look
at a lot of policies you can go back and
see how they're
how they're embedded in anti-blackness
and why
we can't move the needle on certain
policies
thank you for sharing that and i think a
lot of the the bigger challenges
you're right is that it's less than the
policy it's more on the narrative too
because there's certain sides on the
right
they actually don't want to hear that or
it's tough for them to hear that
probably because it cuts against the
first narrative that they earned their
way right the current system was
successful from a dollars and cents
standpoint um
you know we became the wealthiest
country in the world so that's i think
just the numbers
but um busted and twisted and it's in
how we got there
um and
it's now at a point where
sure we're still like you have more and
more and more and more people
piling up at the bottom um and
i'm at the point now and i think many
are where it needs to be fundamentally
shifted and so you can't you can't tweak
on the margins you can't change the
inside
has to be fundamental and that's what
always drew me the universal basic
income it drove me to cash
payments that sort of cash relief
because it would fundamentally
start it wouldn't be the only
fundamental but it would start to
rewrite the rules of the economy where
you
basically your income level doesn't
start at zero
um in your view
you guys are based in oakland um which
uh
nearby stockton california was the first
city to really pilot basic
income on a cash relief standpoint or if
you wanted to start rewriting the
fundamental rules like how would you
how would you go about that right let's
say hey i had the money and i had the
political will
and skill to execute it what does that
mechanically look like on your end
and then maybe we can back into the
narrative that needs to happen to do
that but mechanically and casually what
what are you
how would you envision that from your
end what's really amazing
about the pilots that we're seeing is
it's
it's helping us really think about how
we can design an entire system
right it's it's really um
shredding those myths about what we
think cash would do right it was just
everyone was geared up to think this is
gonna
you know what's gonna happen people are
gonna go out and
not know how to spend the money and this
wouldn't you know make a difference
but what we're seeing is quite the
opposite and
i think you know one living here in
california
knowing that you know wages really just
can't keep up with the
cost of living even with high minimum
wage wage laws here
um that the cost of living is
outstripping um
wages that this this
like pilot of 500 a month made a
significant difference in people's lives
i mean it enabled people to to actually
work more enable people to take care of
their
families meaning those who are
caretakers and and
and we've got to think about the the
care infrastructure i mean it's it's
critical and
coming out of this pandemic um it it
helped people
you know pay down debt it help people
which i think is one of the biggest
issues it gave
people a greater sense of peace of mind
it helped people deal with the stress
and that and all the things that
manifest from stress
from being short on money every month
and so it's teaching us that
we can really have a new way of
operating in this country if we think
about
really moving away from punitive
approaches and
really helping people get what they need
and trusting them to say i know what's
really best for my family
i think you know even looking at the
pilot in jackson mississippi with
with black mothers and saying you know
finally like i can take my kid to the
ocean
you know i can get the extra help in
school
um all the things that make our lives
worth living
you know and i think that uh you know
those
those of us who are really really
believe in
in cash see it for all of those reasons
see it for people's ability to really be
who they're meant to be i mean it's not
going to solve
every issue but certainly it can solve
for
you know being able to say i don't have
to worry whether i'm going to eat next
week
you know i don't have to worry if i have
to juggle between trying to keep the
lights on
and figuring out how to take care of the
needs of my child so
yeah i think that it's it's it's
providing us
with an opportunity to reimagine um a
broken
really you know broken systems that have
been in play for for decades
for us the press narrative that was so
frustrating was that people said andrew
was going to
um get rid of other benefits in addition
to cash and
never said that he said on the on the
margins you could opt in but never ever
said
um and he never would like he's like the
point like if you any anyone
who listens to like why is he running is
to fix it not to cause more problems
geez um
and you're right that there's a you're
not just fighting
a broken political system you're not
just fighting um
even like a status quo or the the
the work like sometimes just passing a
law or lobbying whatever it is
is straight up work and it's time like a
lot of stuff we've done on cash relief
with humanity forward before
um before andrew and i left was like
talking to senators and congresswomen
who had never seen data on this stuff
um they're like oh thanks i'm great i'm
i'm supportive of this i never knew
right so there's like there's work there
but the bigger thing is this
narrative story piece um
let me ask you this when you're um in
the nonprofit world
as much as we want to focus on the work
all day long you also have to focus on
the money and the dollars and the grants
and things like that
from the donor side of things you know
how often
how much education are you doing on your
end to help them understand
um what you're trying to accomplish and
what the actual problems
are or and then are there mistakes or
preconceived notions that you have from
big donors coming in to help because i
always feel like you got the money on
one side
of people on the other and people doing
the work in between um
have you seen that challenge from the
money hitting the org what are your um
you know how have you navigated that as
a leader you know it's it's still
quite a challenge right and i think that
you know i really believe that we need
new models both
in our kind of non-profit industrial
complex
and the way that money is raised through
traditional philanthropy
you know it's it's um very difficult
to think about innovation um because
once you have to prove that and show
that you've done it before people will
actually
invest right and so i feel like we're
we're being stifled a lot on innovation
i mean when you think about this pilot
think about what this one pilot has done
in stockton
um and to really build a national
movement yeah
chicago chica oh yes newark all across
exactly across the country i mean
they're just i hear
about more and more pilots every day
that are that are really focused on
particular populations or to deal with
particular issues
but think about that that was an
innovative approach where
you know um michael tubbs really said i
really want to address this
narrative around poverty i mean i know
the 500 will help people but
fundamentally that's really what i want
to change so i think that there
is there are not as many opportunities
that there should be
to innovate through traditional
philanthropy right
and to do that in a myriad of ways that
you could really take an idea out and
test it you know
um there's a number of things we'd love
to test more and it's
very hard to fundraise for that risk
it's hard to fundraise for risk
it's hard to find a phase for risk but
when we think about other business
models we do it all the time
oh yeah
every right they do it every day and
that's how we think about how we're
going to actually solve these problems
if we don't innovate right um i think
that too
you know it's it is somewhat of a closed
world sometimes you just can't get
funding
you know they you know you have to know
someone who knows someone who knows
someone
of course that's how the world works but
um
you know you know too often you know the
money is so
niched and it's so um you know very
specific
that you've got to go in and you've got
to find that niche there's not a lot of
investment to say look we're going to
just
provide you with some core support so
you can work on all of these things that
you're doing here at the insight center
i think some more funders are coming
around to that
but i think there needs to be a bigger
push in that way if we're going to
actually
be able to move the needle so we
we actually still need better better
models
i think that you know our work we're
small
and we really are just really focused on
digging into root causes of issues and
not everyone wants to fund that right
um and and so but we feel like that's
big important work and we're going to
continue to do it
and continue to push them push the field
and and push on funders and to say these
things because
you know clearly if you're working on
issues around gender and race
you know these are very challenging
issues and it's going to take more than
just traditional kinds of approaches
to get us to a place we need to be you
know
um we've got a big issue coming out of
this out of this
recession out of this pandemic and
that's why there have been
2.3 million women pushed out of the
labor market um
it's it's it's having a monumental
effect on families and everyone that
that's you know sitting in and seeing
partners wives
friends mothers um daughters
you know deal with home schooling and
um working and making having to make
difficult choices
what are we going to do to rebuild our
care infrastructure or to really
reimagine what reimagine it because it
actually needs
uh a lot more than what it had prior to
the pandemic
so these are things that i think you
know
i'd love to see more innovation i love
to see more trust
and you know trust to deliver just like
we're talking about trusting families to
make decisions
of course um so yeah you know there's
there's still room
room uh there a lot of work to do a lot
of work to do there
yeah so i used to work in client
philanthropy and the biggest thing i
tell clients is
the world needs donors to take risk
to be okay with lighting a gift on fire
in terms of failing be okay with failure
because
whether we like it because a lot of
people want to have their legacy they
want to say they help they want to feel
good but the reality is
that's the job of private philanthropy
that's the job um
because the government or big
organizations like
churches or you go down a list of
organizations that can give at
scale if you will um it's mainly the
government they can't take risk
because look i mean the mile tubs like
he took an awesome risk
great booted out um didn't win the next
election like that's what happens when
you take risks as politician um
and now that'll be fair i don't know
enough about that situation you know why
but
really regardless that is a normal thing
in politics and that's where private
philanthropists need to
to give the risk and fund either general
general money for nonprofits and
and um program officers to do work
or i'm gonna fund some research i'm
gonna fund a pilot program
and it may fail but that is our job to
fail right that is our job is the only
way we're gonna learn
yeah so and i wouldn't even say it's
failure you know i mean i i i yeah
you're right it's like so lessons
learned to say well you know what
um you know maybe this wasn't the right
population we need you know we should be
working with this population right
i mean i did that with a middle school
program where we were doing an
intervention and we realized
no it these kids had to have this this
and that right so we just need to kind
of re-gear our program
for a different set of kids and that's
the case so we learn
from these things and then we can
actually continue to innovate so
yeah we need that investment we've gotta
we've gotta and i think that
you know people who are pushing this
forward it's not coming out of nowhere
it's coming out of years of working with
folks coming up years of experience
and it's really trying to put good ideas
to the test
um so yeah definitely yeah some of it's
not going to maybe
have the success we may have won it but
it might show us a better way to kind of
get it done
absolutely and um it's the
the i don't know if it's true or not
that he said it but i believe it's true
is it what edison said when he made the
light bulb he said i didn't you know he
it took him a thousand times he said i
didn't fail a thousand times i found a
thousand
thousand ways to not make a light bulb
and those were always helpful learnings
um
what not gonna be this one and that's
like we we need to have that sort of
this hopeful optimism with our giving um
and spirit of entrepreneurship with our
in our social programs it's one thing i
love about andrew he has
he's so freaking hopeful and abundant
and we need that
if you had infinity all the money
in the world um how would you
spend it to solve um a number of the
issues you're talking about now you may
want to not do
all of them but maybe where would you
spend the unlimited resources
um to fight what you're fighting
it focuses on women and i focus it on
women of color
specifically and you know why it's
because
honestly if those groups are doing well
then everyone's doing well we
continuously
leave folks leaves folks out right and
we're constantly solving for that
or trying to um and then we and we look
at our policies and say oh wait
this group has been left behind right
but you know there's never been a time
where black women have been doing well
well never and
if they were everyone else also wasn't
doing well so
when i say center our work and our
resources
and policies on the most marginalized
it's to really ensure that everyone can
thrive and it's it's a framework to say
we know if those folks are thriving we
have probably designed
policies and systems that work for
everyone so
that's really what i want to get that i
want to i want to
to be able to have these systems work
for everyone when we think about
lifetime earnings that are being
left because of pay inequities and we
think about
when we think about that like it really
means that we could be more prosperous
both as communities and as a nation that
we're just leaving money behind
and really all the problems that come
along with it whether those are health
issues or other things so
yeah that's what i would do definitely i
love that answer
um i saw tom brokaw speak at an event a
while back and he said something really
that stuck with me he said i'm
optim this was probably five years back
he was six years back and he said i'm
optimistic on the future of this country
and he's like for one word women
because we've had this much success in
the united states with half our
population participating um
and to your point like women of color
and um even more so if you're talking
about so
um i met with a um there was a very
very very senior woman um who had worked
at the
um un and world bank like with the
players to put this way that's all i
don't want to give away because at a
certain point there's prospection to
find out who she is
but she had asked that question to a
table of uh our clients at the bank and
then
everybody said well i'd spend on
education i spent on this been on what
you know
their cause of choice if you will and
then i was like well what and then and
put it back on i was like what would you
spend it on
um and she you know she said she said i
would use the money to bribe
elected officials and people in power um
which is a fascinating like mind-blowing
like whoa um
because like they'll actually do it if
they get paid
and maybe that's it but given the fact
that um we are not
you know that's a it's obviously an
exercise what we
to your point like the narrative and the
flow and one of the things i love about
interest like that's what that's where
we need to spend the
the money and energy and time because
one of the things that andrew
when he was fighting for cash relief and
then the coronavirus hit
what happened when that hit mitt romney
the pope
donald trump you had people across the
political spectrum saying oh yeah cash
released a good idea and it's you know
okay and when the narrative changes the
party lines move
right um and the greed moves right so
um i very much agree um
with with the work you're doing and
frankly the way to change narratives
many times is like get people better
data
get people better numbers um show them
the incentives on both sides
um and that requires fighting that
requires like doing the research
grinding it out
getting it right getting the right story
and then pounding the pavement to go
tell
the people the officials the messages
the ads whatever it is so
i mean the work you're doing is is is
meant jenny many ways like real life
superhero work you know what's exciting
you about the future and what this
can look like you know are you seeing
positive movement
on the ground i do feel like there is a
slight or even
i think there's a strong corporate like
at a top narrative shift
um about empowering black women and
empowering communities
um means of color and marginalized
communities but i don't
i'm not extremely confident that that's
not
sadly like a fad if or or like whatever
they're doing for their profits right
now mh yeah i think that might be fickle
um
i could be wrong i hope i'm wrong but
i'm not sure what what is it what is
exciting you
where's that going um you know what does
the future look like in your eyes
that's optimistic yeah i mean i
i kind of agree with you um you know
this could be seen as
a fad um right now i mean we tend to
have short attention spans it's like
you know and so it could be another
issue two years from now
but i think you know i do think this
kind of
push on infrastructure um
and and broadening that notion of
infrastructure
um and the fact that there's you know
support for that
and you know public support for that is
is exciting um because it means that we
can really
reimagine systems that have been in
decay have been neglected and also think
about
about issues in tandem right to think
about jobs and climate change right
to think about you know racial injustice
and and our labor market you know so i'm
excited about the conversations that are
taking place there
i think there is you know a big push to
understand
what this this pandemic has meant to our
economy i think there's some exciting
research happening
to to really to really tell us things
that we're not going to see in our data
for a couple of years and
we're not going to see it all right um
and i think
for us we want to really get down and
and talk to folks in communities
to understand what's happened and what's
really needed
and so i think that there's a great deal
of interest there to actually
you know we're actually trying to solve
for certain problems i mean
i think even with the gi pilots we
are trying to solve for issues around
poverty or
our homelessness um and and bigger
issues like that
i think there's a lot more appetite
for talking about structural change in
ways i haven't seen in many years so
that's kind of exciting
i think we've just got a we've got to
like we've got to push we've got to push
like hell right now because
you know this isn't this is um we're
talking about
you know generations to come and how
they'll be impacted by the decisions
that we make today
when we're seeing um you know such
inequality that continues to widen and
widen and widen
and you know what does this mean for
future generations if we don't tackle
some of these issues what will it mean
if we don't
begin to tackle climate change if we
don't begin to think about
yeah it's it is a disaster and i think
you know
um you know this is a time where we
can't we can't
be complacent we've got to keep pushing
and i'm excited around the
about the energy that i'm seeing even in
communities that are are
really thinking about local ways in
which they can address this level of
inequality so that's exciting
i am excited about that and i think
andrew andrews said this publicly he's
like look whatever
joe biden says or does
no matter how radical can automatically
become mainstream
because of the kind of what their
administration represents
um and i do the broadening of the
definition of infrastructure is so
fascinating
because there was a big movement on the
left to say
gender equality is infrastructure and
xyz is infrastructure and
on the face of it you know if you're
like if you're stuck in the old box
you're like wait a second infrastructure
is like roads and streets so like
it's not but on the other hand you're
like wait a second like if we're
talking about infrastructure in terms
like how this country is
set up and how people operate how people
are able to operate for success within
it then of course it is right like then
so that is what
i think is um i hope is is exciting
um and the answer i'll leave it like
this like andrew and i were talking he's
like look
the answer for those with with means if
you will
and means can be anything not just
dollars with family like a stable
families and opportunities and the
ability to be mobile in this and
participate in this economy
your choice is to keep your money and go
into a bunker
right or to you know like hide um and
just be like and turn a blind eye like
whatever you want to call it or
do something or go fight and i what i
appreciate about
you and your work and what you're doing
is that you're fighting
you're every day it's a fight um it
doesn't always feel like one sometimes
it feels like paperwork but
it's a fight um so um
thank you from the bottom of my heart um
for one teaching me but
to doing what you're doing um and
where can the yang gang and anyone
listening to this where can they find
you and your work
and how can they help you can find us at
insightcced.org
um you know we love donations but we
also just
want people to be engaged with us in
this work those that are interested in
shifting narratives those that are
really interested in
um thinking about how we need to look at
our labor market coming out of this
pandemic and and think about those who
have been
crowded into the the most dangerous jobs
and
those that are are really um you know
really seeing that their income can't
keep up with the cost of living
um those types of issues if you're
really excited about those
love for you to to join us and the work
that we do
we will put the link in the you know in
the description of this episode
but i will say this look if you've known
a great um
of course a nonprofit and much needed
but also i think um
when i was combing through your work and
there's a lot of
research and just thought provoking
pieces you guys have there
so sharing stuff like that and talking
not only just on social media but also
in your daily lives and when you talk
about it and then that's where the real
start change and narrative changes start
happening so
anne price thank you
thank you for all you do thank you for
being awesome thank you for fighting
and i look forward to um talking to you
soon thank you zach
take care
you